مع الهتافتنا
المغرب كيخلع شرب ماء الامريكان
المغرب
[موسيقى]
احنا بالمغرب
مباراه بس للمباراه نعم شهدنا الكثير من
الذين اتىوا اليوم صباحا او ظهرا للمباراه
والكثير منهم كان يفكر العوده ولكن اعتقد
سيغير رايك يا رشا يعني
ان شاء الله مع البرتغال واحد صفر مره
البرتغال وحنمر واحد صفر على المغرب ان
شاء الله المغرب بيمثل كل العرب نتمنى
يعني نمثلوا العرب الكل احسن تمثيل وتحيه
للمنتخب المغربي وتحيه للجمهور الكبير
المغربي
والله ان شاء الله
ده عبر قناه كوم اسيا العربيه كانوا وجه
شكر خاص لجماهير المغربيه المتوجه داخل
المغرب وخارج المغرب واللي كانت في الملعب
والشجعات وسانده المنتخب الوطني المغربي
اللي شرفنا بهذه الفوز هذا وان شاء الله
لما لا نفوز بالكاس في دوله عربيه
اليوم هو يوم مشهود في تاريخ العرب
دوله عربيه هي المغرب واقصى دوله
الفرصه اليوم بيننا اقصى دوله في الشرق
بحس في دمع بعيونك والله صحيح همم
جميع جميع
العرب
يعني الحضاره القطري في نصف صلاه العرب
وكندا بان هادي بدايه جديده
شعوب وشكرا ليكم وشكرا للعربيه